good morning john i've been doing some
thinking about how i became me
which is not clear but there have been
important moments on that road i was
once at a dance at a summer camp for
example the thing about summer camp
that's a little weird is that there's a
lot of people who are young young people
but they are not all the same age but
they are all occupying somewhat the same
like social environment which like
looking beyond modern times had to be
entirely the norm but these days seems a
little bit like you put the high scores
with the high schoolers and the middle
schoolers with the middle schoolers in
the elementary school with the
elementary school not sure what that
accent was the important thing here
though is that like i'm 11 or 12 and i'm
at a dance and there are kids dancing in
this place and you should imagine me
standing over by the benches
experiencing some second-hand
embarrassment there's this other kid
he's maybe two years older than me i
don't know him very well but he is a
nerd he is a big huge nerd and he is
dancing way too
much like it's definitely not like good
dancing it's not like fantastic dancing
and it's but it's a lot it looks like
he's working pretty hard at it not that
i knew anything about dancing i knew
like that you're supposed to look cool
while you're doing it which what does
that mean who knows and regardless it's
been a long time i don't actually
remember what this could look like i
remember that i looked at him and i
thought that's embarrassing here's what
i do remember there was a young woman
who was older than me like higher status
than me maybe 16 years old and she
said to me
in a very sympathetic tone
i know i wish i could dance like him too
and my entire life changed
like
what not only did she think that he was
a good dancer she
couldn't believe that i was looking at
him for any other reason she had
misinterpreted cringe for envy so here's
what happened from that day forward i
was never anyone but my true authentic
self and i did absolutely everything i
felt i should do and everyone loved me
for it no none of none of that what i
did do is i took what she had offered
though i don't think that she meant it
as an offering i took it and like i
believed her
i
accepted her version of that reality
that at that moment i had no question in
my mind that everybody in the world felt
the exact same way that i did about that
guy's dancing but she showed me that
that wasn't true and in fact that she
was impressed by him and she was older
than him so i did like start to take up
more space
and live through moments where i wasn't
sure what everyone would think of what i
was doing or how i was acting because
like
who knows
like who knows i let her be one of the
voices in my head certainly not the only
one but one of them if you go bigger if
you try harder some people are probably
gonna think wow that is so cringe but
some people might think man i wish i
could dance like him too neither of
those people um the dancer or the
commenter remember that moment i can
guarantee you that because like i
remember
a tiny tiny tiny fraction of the moments
of those years here's the real wild
thing they might very well know who i am
now because they've seen crash course or
something but have no idea that they met
me
in 1991 and yet those two people who had
no idea what they were doing i think had
a pretty big impact on me because like
putting myself out there is not natural
for me like this is my extreme sport
like i like this the way that some
people like jumping out of planes i had
plenty of agency into how to work with
that moment like it's not a story that
is about me not being in control of my
life but like
that's a really little moment it was a
very few words that i do feel like has
had a
pretty tremendous impact which makes me
feel uh
happy
john i'll see you on tuesday